welcome to this video playing Jana was a
[ __ ] I don't think he has got a name in
that but he's very high rated oops not
the local to 5505 and we have a semi
tirage kind of position check check
yeah this is an a-line that was popular
on a long time ago but it recently
gained some new popularity there has
been played by pry Kramnik amongst
others not sure about this move or is
this is this right toggle d5 now is
going to play what Knight f6 Mary ok but
their first let's just let's just
centralized pieces him
one good aspect for blankets that he's
got a pretty simple way to deploy the
pieces he's pretty much putting we
should be 797 usually am it goes the
Queen goes to eat seven not here but
okay why why not you just protect the
center I'm not quite sure what my plan
is here d5 and d5
d5 is probably going to play me five
yeah but he 5 Queen somewhere and then
d5 he probably has a night c5
hmm not sure how to continue here this
is a kind of either know what to do
96 i'm going to play g3 it looks a bit
ugly i will play d5 if he lets me
this loose night on the diagonal is ugly
I hope it damn it there is no the new
direct punishment for that covering c3
so that I can plenty 50 okay so should I
go d 5 point why not centralized this 96
I've Knight g4
you
I'm not sure that this is really netting
anything
95 maybe not see five
hmm clear
maybe can play 97 I didn't look at that
knight c6
ah what deck i can i can actually this
is not a neat trick Queen now d7 I can
play Queen c3 are not Quincy three okay
I know I can play Quincy 397
takes politics there's always 97 which I
of course didn't plan or anything
beforehand and it's not clear that this
is actually helping me it can maybe play
some other moves
oops didn't consider that one but Rock
d7 isn't this dangerous attending 97 a
seven and the check
hmm
he has to check him but I've got King
King edge true yeah what the technical
myth
check
maybe something better okay this is a
piece at the mode 96 is actually a fun
way to can to secure the peace because
of the mate
check
check move the pawn the screen a des
night g6 mate
check check check
time warning check check check check
check Stan no one no no no no no no that
knight on f6 oh the knight on f6 10
seconds I have 10 seconds against five I
can do any move not King age five ahh
this hurts yeah yeah I shouldn't even
play at six right okay i was just in in
in in blitz mode yeah what a shame i
really liked it I mean it wasn't wasn't
even was quite young take the gang a
technical play check getting all the
porn happy jack the occasional check
little trick in there I'm still meeting
him ah what bag you have very very
complicated position I think in the
tactical complications here here here he
needs to play another move yeah Queenie
a this is winning Queen your sex is the
normal move but it the problem is that
after Queenie six
I really have this one and and now this
is this is really neat because he cannot
prevent this 97 idea and this means he
taking doesn't really help him um yeah
but this this even lost our rocky fibers
even stronger okay but this is a check
at least winning a piece I should go to
f8 yeah why not actually didn't we see
that nitrous citizen is an interesting
try here check yeah probably this will
we draw at the end so this wasn't wasn't
Desai slang but after this it was can't
just down oops just a piece up which I
converted nicely until I hit stalemated
him alright thanks for watching